[Musique]
le moment où la rentrée parlementaire se
déroule je voudrais revenir sur le rôle
de l'opposition des républicains nous
sommes l'opposition Emmanuel Macron pas
l'opposition comme le rassemblement
national ou la gauche qui se réjouit de
l'échec Emmanuel Macron nous sommes une
opposition qui veut tout au contraire
faire pression sur le gouvernement pour
lui faire accepter des mesures que nous
croyons utiles aux Français que nous
croyons bonne pour le pays c'est le
fondement même de l'esprit des
responsabilités qui nous anime ne nous
trompons pas dans l'analyse qui peut
être faite des votes des députés les
républicains bien souvent les votes
lorsqu'ils sont positifs c'est parce que
les textes contiennent des mesures que
nous avons imposé au gouvernement sur
lequel nous avons fait pression
depuis bien entendu lorsque viendront
des textes sur lesquels nous ne
partageons rien et sur lesquels nous
n'aurons pas pu imposer nos votes et
bien l'opposition prendra c'est pleine
responsabilités